when I think about I'm a huge fan thank
you so much when I think about brand
building and the Real Housewife Empire
you're sort of the original you were a
personal chef
you had an unbelievably hot body you
were drinking these margaritas on air
people said how do I drink as much as
she does and look as good as she does
and that's how the brand seemingly that
someone watching was born well but now
when I watch it seems that every single
woman in this never-ending Real
Housewives Mathia
every time they bend over they say uh
time for me to build up make a workout
video so it has brand building been
destroyed by the franchise I don't think
it's been destroyed I'm sitting here
looking around in the world of business
and I'm thinking it's funny how you can
make your market in unsuspected places I
mean unexpected places
I mean the Real Housewives is in a place
you'd think that you would build a brand
but maybe although so many people watch
it so many people watch it right well
that was what my reason for doing it was
but that was kind of a really unfamiliar
concept at that time and now since then
watching what I've done people have
created their own liquor brands and
books and videos but the truth of the
matter is business is really difficult
and you have to be passionate and driven
and most of them haven't succeeded
because you have to have an idea that's
innovated you have to be able to execute
and you can't look to the left of the
right to what someone else is doing to
figure out what you're doing I cracked
the code and did something that had
never been done before in liquor and it
really wasn't because I had a nice
figure and it wasn't because it was a
businesswoman I connected with the
audience my I connected with the
audience as a human being with my flaws
and my life and that is ultimately why
they trusted me to buy my products it
wasn't the other way around I went on
the show to show what I was doing but
that isn't the reason that I ended up
becoming successful then why go back to
the show you are the clear winner when
in terms of brand building and what they
have created nobody else has really done
it your back kind of with those who have
lost at the game it's true but I missed
that connection with the audience that
is the grass roots of what I've done and
going away people saw me on Forbes
magazine and read about all the money
and think that I've changed and don't
really know me that well anymore and I
missed the connection I miss going
through things with them and I've had
some personal struggles and I missed
showing my perspective and just I'm a
relatable woman okay
isn't there a risk there though Bethenny
because business is respectable you're
building a respectable business you want
to be known for respectability and
you're going back to a show that people
think of quite often it's disrespectful
because this respectable because it
stands for some of the things that are
kind of wrong with America dysfunctional
families consumerism the glorification
of wealth and plastic-surgery the list
goes on I love that question and look
around you if everyone here is it taking
risks right now at their desks that's
what I do when I went on I had already
been on The Apprentice I was a runner up
I had a small little profile and people
said it's gonna be a bunch of people
getting drunk you're gonna be a train
wreck if it's successful it's because it
is a train wreck and I said you know
what it's not that easy to get on
television and market what you're doing
and I took that risk and I'm good I'm
doubling down I left and I'm going back
because I feel comfortable there I was
offered four or five other television
shows and this is a plate I've accepted
the fact that I am a professional
reality star and this is I am good at it
but at some point when I look at the
Kardashians I think they have made so
much money when did they say this isn't
worth it my pride somewhere there has to
be a value for my pride I don't want to
put my life out there you know you're
saying you've learned from your mistakes
being out there maybe caused problems
why not say I've made all this money let
me take my life back let me take it off
the stage I love that too I enjoy
inspiring women I have written eight
books not because I have to write books
I could be just peddling my margaritas
chips and non alcoholic beverages I
write books because of my personal
experiences as a woman that's part of
what defines me
and women connect to the fact that I've
gone through a terrible divorce that I
was in my thirties didn't know if I'd
have a child I was broke I that I thrive
on that if I have difficulty and someone
else can be helped I don't do it in
trashy on the show you can watch this
whole show and the show has changed
that's why the season the ratings are up
22 percent from last year
because I'd has integrity but I'm not
here's beneath you on the show are the
other women no no one's beneath me we're
all it's like working at an office we
all are at the same level there's eight
of us and we all need each other they
needed me for the show but I need them
too I want to know Bethenny who you
turned down to go back to real housewife
I turned down shark tank I turned down
Dancing with the Stars I turned down the
Celebrity Apprentice I turn down
sharknado 2 I turned down my producer is
going to be to see you on all of those I
got asked what in terms of brand
building do you look at the Kardashians
as the ultimate no I don't
who is because I do and I don't know I
think they're the ultimate in monetizing
and making money and coming in and the
smash-and-grab job but if I had to think
about is that is the Kardashian brand is
it sex is it beauty is it just the
American dream of being able to I'm not
exactly sure what the brand is so I
wouldn't say it's the ultimate and brand
building the ultimate brand builder the
ultimate brand builder could be anybody
from in my business from bidding no
Steve Jobs Paul Newman there you go
rusty I mean you know Steve Jobs
Mark Zuckerberg